(light music)
- [Narrator] Utilizing one of the most
efficient natural camouflages on earth,
this is the pink winged stick insect.
(light music)
True to its name, the
pink winged stick insect
does resemble a stick.
They have been observed making
repetitive side-to-side movements,
mimicking a stick blowing in the wind.
As camouflage is their biggest defense,
many stick insects are nocturnal
and in the face of an
attack, will play dead.
Some have been seen to even
shed a limb to evade a predator.
Long and thin, these insects
range between 13 and 21 inches
in length, with females
being longer than the males.
Little is known about stick
insects, making it difficult
to declare the vulnerability
of their status in the wild.
However, this one is endemic to Madagascar
and was listed as an endangered species
due to aggressive
deforestation in the area.
This is the pink winged stick insect.
(light music)